we've just had a statement in From Grace
O'Malley Kumar's family Grace we now
know was a first year medical student
she was coming to the end of her first
year at Nottingham University we know
she was a talented hockey player who was
described as a popular member of the
England under 16 and under 18 Squad she
also played for Nottingham University
but her family have this to say this
afternoon
Grace was an adored daughter and sister
she was a truly wonderful and beautiful
young lady Grace was not just a sister
to James but his best friend he is
completely heartbroken as parents words
cannot explain our complete and utter
Devastation she will be so dearly missed
we were so incredibly proud of Grace's
achievements and what a truly lovely
person she was she was resilient and
wise Beyond her years Grace was so happy
in life fulfilling her ambition of
studying to become a doctor whilst
playing Top Flight hockey at University
she leaves behind devastated extended
family and friends we request that all
media Outlets stop invading our privacy
while we face this sorrow this is a
statement from the family of 19 year old
Grace O'Malley
Kumar the family ending that statement
with a request for privacy so Grace
O'Malley Kumar a statement from her
family there described as an adored
daughter and sister a truly wonderful
and beautiful young lady